ومن سلقين في ريفي ادلب معنا مراسلنا صهيب
الخلف اذا صهيب ما زالت الصور التي تردنا
صور مؤلمه قاسيه جدا انت الان امام مستشفى
سلقين كما نلاحظ مستشفى سبقين المركزي ما
الذي شاهدته صف لنا الاجواء عندك
نعم امام زحمه الجثث وتكدسها على الرصيف
المستشفى لتسليمها الى ذويها تاتي بارقه
امل قبل قليل وصل شخص حي الى هذا المستشفى
وهو بصحه جيده ادخل الى المستشفى حتى يصار
الى فحص حالته الصحيه ومعي هنا المدير
الطبي للمستشفى الدكتور عبد العزيز عبد
العزيز ليتحدث لنا عن عمل المستشفى في
اسعاف الناس وتقديم الخدمات الاسعافيه
للناجين من تحت الانقاض الدكتور عبد
العزيز الحمد لله على سلامتكم
عمل المستشفى
والصعوبات والامل الذي ياتيكم من خلال
وصول الناس الاحياء
استاذي الكريم الوضع حاليا صاحب المشفى
الوضع بسلقين بالمجمل وضع كارثي عدد
الوفيات كبير جدا لليوم الصبح للساعه
ثمانيه الصبح اكثر من 300 وفاه من الصبح
لهلا 35 وفاه تقريبا عدل الوفيات فقط حاول
335 ولكن الصراحه نشيل بيخلينا نتامل لسا
من دقيقتين شفت يمكن دخل الشاب شالوه لسعه
على قيد الحياه اموره ان شاء الله جيده ان
شاء الله وان شاء الله هالشي بتدعونا
نتفائل في ناس تحت الانقراض على قيد
الحياه ان شاء الله بالمجمل وضع صعب صرنا
نحن تقريبا هلا يومين وشوي على المستقبل
تقريبا فوق 700 اصابه عدد الوفيات مثل
حوالي 335 وفاء لحد اللحظه هلا الوضع صعب
جدا اول يوم كان الوضع ماساوي جدا صعوبات
كبيره بصراحه واجهتنا بسبب عدد اصابات
الكبير جدا طبعا يعني
الريف العاصي والكامل صافي اصابات بسنه
عزمارين اصابات لعنا
بعض الاطباء في المجاوره اضطرينا نحول عدد
كبير جدا من الاصابات عدد وفيات كان كتير
كبير الناس للاسف ما كثير قدرنا نتعرف
عليهم
واضطروا الدفاع المدني يشيلهم بصراحه هاي
بالصوره مختصره الوضع الحالي شكرا لكم
دكتور يعني انتم في قلب المنطقه الحدوديه
التي تعرضت للزلزال وكان عملكم صعبا شكرا
شكرا نعم القصص التي يمكن ان نرويها ايضا
عن ذوي
العالقين تحت الانقاض وهم يترقبون اي خبر
عن ذويهم قبل قليل وصل شاب حي وكان معه
اهله سنلتقي بابو خالد لو سمحت
حدثنا كيف جرت عمليات الانقاذ وكيف اخرج
ابنكم من تحت الانقاض الحمد لله الحمد لله
اشكر الله كانوا سته
اربع دفناهن وضلوا اثنين ضل حمود وابوه
حمود انقذناه اشكر انقاذ واشكر كل الاخوه
وكل من ساهم اشكر الله الحمد لله كل
الاحوال الحمد لله
الحمد لله يا رب والشكر لله
كمان ابوه بلكي ابوك كمان يطلع عايش يا رب
هذا طلع من السته عايش دفعنا اربعه هو
ابوه يطلع ابوك اشكر الله يا رب يا رب
يا رب ان شاء الله يطلعوا سالمين هو ابن
اخ ابي خالد خرج من المستشفى خرج من تحت
الانقاض قبل قليل ووصل الى المستشفى وهو
بصحه جيده رغم مرور يومين واليوم الثالث
على وجوده تحت الانقاض هذا يعطي املا
كبيرا ودافعا للفرق الانقاذ ولفرق الدفاع
المدني وللمتطوعين المدنيين معهم لمواصله
العمل ولتسريع وتيره العمل رغم الصعوبات
الكبيره رغمار الكبير رغم وجود ايضا عشرات
العالقين تحت الانقاض وتفرق المناطق التي
تعرضت لاضرار لكن فرق الانقاذ ما زالت
تعمل وما زالت تحاول رفع الانقاض وهناك
العديد من الاشخاص الذين يتم انتشالهم
طبعا هناك فرحه عا هنا في المستشفى وصل
اهل الشخص الذي اخرج حيا من تحت الانقاض
نعم نعم
الحمد لله
يا شباب انا حمود ابن الصيدلي طالعوني
نسمع صوته يا رب وفي شبك حياك الله حاط
قدامك في عالم وراي وين ابوك يا ابويا انا
خدام ابوي وما بعرف
على امه واخواته يا رب تعطينا القائد يا
الله
اذا تجارب مريره قضاها الاشخاص الذين
ينتظرون خبرا عن ذويهم الذين ما زالوا
عالقين تحت الانقاض وصول شخص حي يعني اعطى
املا كبيرا هنا وفرحا عند الناس نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك صهيب خلف يعني دموع اسى
ودموع فرح تختلط وفي النهايه طبعا المصاب
مؤلم وكبير ولكن تسليط الضوء عليه مهم جدا
في هذه الفتره الحاسمه التي
تشهد حاجه كبيره للمساعدات